votre nouveau livre est un roman hybride
entre une pièce de théâtre est un roman
mais ça dit que c'est un roman qui
contient une pièce de terre j'ai
retrouvé la même plaisir que j'avais
tout jeune en découvrant vos premières
pièces d'auteurs fait que visiblement
vous avez gardé votre style
cette cellule est différente c'est
peut-être parce que vous avez
l'impression de me découvrir
je me souviens quand je fais lire le
livre à brand il m'a dit mais pouvait y
était si tu veux faire un check-up foyer
temps beach et où libre de la pièce que
je lui dis faut quand même
chabat sens mais faut quand même qu'ils
aient qu'on retrouve des morceaux tout
en étant un hommage à un autre auteur
faut qu'on retrouve le style aussi de
l'auteur situe la pièce vous avez fait
les votre manuscrit à rendre le brassard
rouge c'est à la base un accord
aujourd'hui encore on se parle pas on
sait qu puis j envoie chaque dimanche et
envoie ce que j'ai dit en semaine puis
j'attends c'est direction fait que la
miss est encore intacte house et votre
complice vous êtes 2 juillet à oui
absolument
ensemble on peut changer puisqu'un peu
ça ils habitent ici il ya quelque chose
qui a cassé un moment donné mais ce que
j'ai vu une pièce là dessus que
j'appelle 10 ans enzo da après l'amour
et il y avait quelque chose la personne
que tu aimes plus est la même les ses
qualités sont les mêmes ces défauts sont
les mêmes l'ailier rapport ont changé
mais si je faisais la personnalité de
chacun
ce que tu aimais chez l'autre reste
encore le carnet je suis renversé a
besoin mais ça mais où ça m'étonne pas
ce que j'ai a pas que vous aviez des
deux grands créateurs tous les douze
avait profondément marqué le québec des
années 70 et 80 avec des mises en scènes
les plus exceptionnels et vous savez qu
ensemble
vous êtes beaucoup plus fort qu
individuellement mais bon ça peut plus
travailler que bae
pour les raisons qu'on sait mais c'est
encore un grand esprit je ne sois pas
rester une grande intelligence
jusqu'à sa mort vous parlez de la
difficulté d'être écrivain et vous
écrivez vous n'avez pas d'être dépassé
vraiment oui à un certain âge vers
belles chances que tous les atouts sont
comme ça un artiste qui est inquiet ou
qui ne doute répond c'est pas un artiste
alors quand on quand on atteint la
société afin moi ça m'est tombé dessus
quand j'ai atteint mes mes 60 ans c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait des choses des choses
qui sont appréciés d'autres moins mais
quand il ya d'autres générations qui
viennent quand 60 ans il ya deux
générations dernier à toi y est le
pionnier de deux presque trois langues
commencent à se poser des questions
parce que c'est ce que peut être une
pièce de 50 ans qui fonctionne depuis 50
ans c'est bien évident que les jeunes
qui vont enlever ce qu'ils vont produire
votre différence une image que je donne
tout le temps que je souhaite une image
avait pour moi il est très juste c'est
quand on va à québec
j'ai toujours un moment avec g en ville
ou de montmel temps sur une voie
d'évitement pour laisser passer en train
de marchandises qui doit plus être et
qui paye plus probable le même temps et
de passage et ça paye moins que rennes
marchandises et chaque fois à une heure
précise il atteint parce que tout
d'abord et quand j'ai atteint la
soixantaine
je me suis senti un petit peu comme ça
je me suis posé la question est une
tendance qui va me dépasser je trouvais
que ces images étaient justes puis sept
ans plus tard choquel et encore je sais
tu parles que que la société te fait une
voie d'évitement non mais qu un moment
donné quelqu'un vient de dire bon
boîtier du bafin ben bouhout est une des
belles choses le groupe permissionnaires
en cause beaucoup mais j'ai peut-être
temps que bon en terminant michel
tremblay vous avez écrit que la pire
chose qui peut arriver un artiste c'est
d'abdiquer est ce qu'un jour vous voyez
arrêter d'écrire et qu'est-ce que vous
avez encore sujet rien à dire ce que
j'en connaisse je ne sais pas j'ai
absolument aucune idée
j'ai plus d'expérience comme je dis
toujours je suis mieux quand j'avais 20
ans j'ai vu des choses que je vais
probablement exprimés mais qu'est ce que
je vais faire dans quoi je vais me
lancer je ne sais pas que c'est assez
excitant de pop en savoie et encore une
fois je disais putallaz le jour j'aurais
pu rien à dire je vais peut-être me fait
de la peine ce avant de déchirer mais
jamais j'impose aller une chose que je
pensais être mauvaise jamais chargé de
promesses le jeu si j'écris quelque
chose que moi je trouve moins bonne je
vois là maintenant phone est très loin
et je vais essayer de l'oublier sans en
être capable probable michel tremblay
merci